[Music]
where am I
what's going on oh you just woke up from
a long call my sweetheart you're in the
hospital
okay can you get my doctor oh wow just
because I'm a woman I can't be your
doctor
women are a lot of things now sweetie
thank you very much
yeah no I'm sorry I was just surprised
Ghostbusters they're women now did you
know that I think I heard that actually
and the movie was awful women can suck
now - okay
women cassette now they're also doing
all-female reboots of Ocean's eleven 21
Jump Street and what about Bob does that
intimidate you no actually that sounds
really fun I would did you know that
which house key brothers are women now
yeah that's right honey women can be
brothers now too
well I don't think that technically they
can oh we can baby and we do put that in
your penis pipe and smoke it
okay I'm sorry I think we got off on the
wrong foot women happy now tell look
there's another female doctor we're
everywhere bitch
hey I'm a man men can have long hair No
- oh that one's on me my bad okay uh I'm
sorry I get it women can do anything a
man can do thank you so there must be a
female president by now huh oh hell you
just go there you know what when they
can smell your laughs - now
Oh
you